in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
americans is far greater than what
divides us
many u.s farmers are planning to retire
in the next five years and it's not
clear
who will replace them one group in
virginia may have a solution
military veterans they're being trained
not only to do the job but also to help
some of the millions of people
who don't have easy access to fresh
fruits and vegetables
chip reid met some of those farmers in
alexandria virginia chip good morning
well good morning here at arcadia farm
the philosophy is that veterans
have exactly the skills that are needed
to become successful farmers and if
you're wondering what
farmers and veterans have in common well
the answer is
a lot jenny haskemp
spent 15 years as a united states marine
now she's a farmer with a focus on
flowers
these are what i want but i want healthy
healthy zinnias she learned the science
and the art
of farming here at arcadia farm in
alexandria virginia on land once owned
by george washington
it's exhausting it's hot it's buggy and
it's the most
satisfying and the happiest i've ever
been she began
three years ago in arcadia's part-time
veteran farmer reserve program that
gives veterans an opportunity
to decide if farming is for them for her
it was a perfect fit i think it's an
incredible program for veterans
transitioning
from years of service into the next
career
she now farms here full time and dreams
of one day
having a small farm of her own being
selected with the kale
about 125 veterans have learned to farm
at arcadia and most including army
veteran marcus roberson
developed a passion for growing fruits
and vegetables
what are you growing here right in
between us we have some strawberries
to my left we have some garlic to my far
left we have cucumbers
we're also growing pumpkins watermelons
tomatoes here what did you feel like
that first time you put your fingers in
the soil here
terrified terrified i had no clue what i
was doing
or when to do it or how or even why for
that matter
but over four years with help from
arcadia farms experts
he figured it out do you think of
yourself as a farmer now
yes yes i'm even thinking of changing my
name
farmer marcus pamela hess is executive
director of arcadia farm and helped
create the veteran farmer program
the goal is to give veterans an
opportunity to earn a living
in a new but surprisingly similar walk
of life
they can work in all temperatures they
can carry
very heavy loads they are great at
long-term planning they are not freaked
out by crisis
farmers and military folks have a very
similar mindset when it comes to their
work farming is a mission-oriented
business in the same way that a military
mission is you can't stop at five
o'clock you stop when the mission is
done
we caught up with hess at arcadia's
mobile market
which sells the farm's fresh produce in
several underserved
neighborhoods in washington d.c in
neighborhoods that don't have grocery
stores that have a high use of food
stamps and low car ownership
which means that people have a really
hard time getting their hands on good
quality
beautiful healthy food government
nutrition benefits are accepted here
and the markets many regular customers
say it's the only place in the area with
food this fresh you love kale yes you
wash it and cut it up
and it holds like if you make your salad
today
and put in the refrigerator is still
going to be fresh
the next day there are many people in
this area over here when the apartments
who do not have transportation and
they need to have fresh produce the
mobile market has seen double-digit
growth every year since 2012. hess gives
most of the credit to her team of
veterans
arcadia farm we don't just grow food we
also grow
farmers farmers who after serving the
nation
have found their next mission the best
part of being out here is
realizing that i can succeed that i can
do things i never
plan to do and i can do more than i
thought that i could still do
allow yourself to see what's possible to
see the potential to see
what you can do don't be afraid to dream
don't be afraid to try don't be afraid
to fail
and know that if we're lucky tomorrow's
another day
and one other thing this program is not
just for veterans they also accept some
active duty service members who are
trying to get a head start on deciding
if
life on the farm is the life for them
vlad chip that last sound bite from
farmer marcus is one that i'm going to
write down
that don't be afraid to dream don't be
afraid to dream don't be afraid to fail
well i'm afraid of that
but i do like it but you never do you
can just never do it like he's about
ready to start i know
chip thank you very much that was
wonderful you look good out there with
that greenery
armor chip yeah you look good yeah i
might have found my next career
okay for us as always we thank you chip
appreciate it